acheter du lait à l'épicerie c'est un
geste qui peut sembler banal mais en
hiver quand le temps est mauvais
derrière chaque litre de lait se cache
un parcours parfois épiques
un matin d'hiver à la ferme brune oui
fiche de saint henri près de lévis
le mauvais temps qui s'en vient ils
vendent pas mal on a des chances qu'on a
des bons charles desgrandchamps mais le
vent vient de loin sa classe et des
places qui va quand même cool
les vaches ne connaissent pas les
saisons elle se présente ou robots et
donne le relais 35 litres par jour
chacune
[Musique]
c'est ainsi paraître tempête journée
terriers ont rejoint les fériés ses
vingt quatre à cinq ans un jour ça que
dire à vos fonctions
[Musique]
à mosport dehors du robot ici et elle
fume des parcours 10 et stanley ce jeu
soudain la maîtrise j'ai presque failli
tomber dans le réservoir pour être
précis le plus rapidement possible à 4
degrés celsius pour la consommation au
la caravane de les moeurs avant ces
lettres
[Musique]
le lait cru est collectée aux deux jours
pas plus
encore ce matin au québec trois cent
cinq camions sont sur les routes
un parcours de 28 millions de kilomètres
par année
à la ferme bruno le lait est transporté
par prolait sur le territoire de
l'entreprise
les hommes ramasse un million de litres
par jour
[Musique]
le répartiteur les suit à la trace c'est
quelque chose elle - l'eau puis on va
regarder ensemble
merci salut environnement canada publie
un avertissement de tempête hivernale
je suis aujourd'hui on voit le à
montmagny viennent de fermer les écoles
cet après midi
levy montmagny bellechasse nous sommes
dans la région la plus venteuses du
québec
l'effet entonnoir créé par le
rétrécissement du fleuve à québec
accélère les vents du nord-est à la
proche de la dépression venant de
l'ouest
le mauvais temps s'installe si la neige
est fraîche et les bancs de neige très
haut
la visibilité est réduite février et
mars sont les pires mois comme le
transport du lait sans que ça prend des
ddd bon chauffeur pourrait recommencer
le lait lait dans ces secteurs losc
le ministère des transports réagit vite
dès que les personnes sont en danger les
routes ferment
aussitôt que la route fringues la 132
l'iran de travail le kesk encore on
parle de la région de bellechasse le 219
217 l'avenue 86 campsas affirme c'est ce
que l'on peut pas se rendre à la firme
pour annoncer les six après deux jours
le lait n'est pas ramassés le producteur
doit le détruire comme ça arrive une
deux fois par hiver chez still bruno on
a embauché deux ouvreurs la valve du
réservoir puis jeté notre les dents dans
la fosse à fumier l'avait de nos
équipements pour partir en neuf avec des
bassins propre une réserve collective
des producteurs va compenser steve mais
à tout coup
c'est quand même la déception si mal au
coeur parce que c'est vraiment notre
notre passion qu'on est obligé de
l'acheter parce qu'on n'est pas de
l'aide de la roya cause des températures
[Musique]
le lait est périssable l'entreposage et
limité retardé ou annulé une livraison
bouleverse tout le circuit de collecte
de livraison et de transformation y a
personne dans l'industrie qui ont
intérêt à ce qu'on dispose du lait c'est
évitable et donc l'ensemble des maillons
de la chaîne vont prendre des
dispositions pour qu'on les vite le plus
possible depuis cinq ans le volume d'eau
n'est éliminé varie de 500 millilitres à
un million deux cent mille litres de
lait par année ce sont aussi des fois
les quantités peuvent sembler important
pour être conscient qu'on produit 65
millions de litres de lait par semaine
en moyenne
ça reste que les producteurs produisent
du lait pour nourrir les gens c'est
leurs soins là que l'un servent à
fabriquer des produits laitiers alors de
produire du lait qui servira pas et qui
sera disposé sait jamais une situation
heureuse prendre du temps d'année en
année c'est un peu plus long que les
routes
ils ferment plus tôt on connaissait le
transport en avion en partance pour jean
cadorette le pire épisode remonte à mars
2008 où certains producteurs ont dû
jeter le lait deux fois la même semaine
j'ai même un chauffeur de la qui est
resté pris dans un récente journée
l'aurait il reste ainsi dans son camion
parce qu'il la respecte et ça va envoyer
une machinerie
ils faisaient pour vous
pour aujourd'hui steve n'est pas inquiet
la route peut fermer le réservoir est à
moitié plein et les vaches sont le
relais tranquille et facebook fasse pas
votre choix
autre innovation il est très doué là où
continuent de panama la météo on
approchera
[Musique]